we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p speaking of
ignorance that is exactly what this
voicemail question is about take a
listen hey David I was just gonna make
this question quick um what's your
opinion on Americans expecting their
self-inflicted ignorance thank you yeah
I I would actually put it a different
way it's not about Americans accepting
self-inflicted ignorance there are
Americans who wear that ignorance like a
badge of honor because they have been
bamboozled by the Republican Party into
believing education is liberal
indoctrination you don't need to be
history who cares what other countries
think and do who cares where America we
do what we want we know what is best we
know what is right it doesn't matter
what anybody else does so it's actually
worse than merely accepting that
self-inflicted ignorance it is a
movement that wears it as a badge of
honor and that is the scariest part of
it and I don't know what is going to
turn it around we've got a great bonus
show for you today a Republican
candidate has been charged with
distributing fake sample ballots on
election day Krispy Kreme Doughnuts has
struck a very interesting deal with a
college kid who drives hundreds of miles
to resell their Donuts and we will talk
about a very interesting study out of
Japan about the four-day Work Week not
Tim Ferriss 4-hour workweek we're not
there yet but the four-day workweek all
of those stories and more on today's
bonus show I hope you'll join us there
you can get instant access by becoming a
member at david pakman.com slash
membership or a patron at patreon.com
slash david pakman show